and so you've got three kinds of
diagrams now and we have more or less
the same result but we handle each one
ever so slightly differently so under
start with this one this is what I call
the line of sight today because I think
that's the easy way to assure but its
formal name it it's not a loving to make
a this company is a plane table radio
service our queen and in a flat surface
as opposed to the plain cake without
much baby
in fact it's so I want you to look at us
wherever you got this now let's just
revise what are you doing this thing you
went outside someone in in the middle of
the field or middle someplace in the
middle and then you sent people off in
all these different directions
okay the reason why this to revise for
those of you especially you didn't do it
this way to work shutting down the
reason why I'm calling a line of sight
trigger service is how do you know where
each of these directions is one of the
most helpful ways is to take your piece
of paper where you're drawing it and you
put down on a plane on a flat surface
maybe you put it on the ground on the
grass maybe put it on the cricket pitch
whatever you put it there down the
ground and then as you send people off
to walk in different directions
you literally destroy it draws a line
from your page in the middle off in the
direction that they're walking down the
line is fine okay so that's where all
the big ones come from they hit an edge
like sense or steps to a car or
something like that and then they take
that measures and free of that so this
is what we ended up so far from remains
now then what we do the whole page is
not the field or whatever it is we're
measuring the whole page is just we're
responsible diagram if you recall what
we want to do now is draw the outline
okay so my advice is go through the
longest length on your diagram which in
this
70 commuters place your ruler against it
and then pick a number on there that
fits in pretty well with 72 meters now
one your diagram maybe conveniently you
can fit 72 millimeters on there so if
you can fit a 7 point 2 centimeter line
from CDC are that perfect if I'm going
from 72 metres to 72 millimeters I'm
going to write that
how many millimeters are there in a
meter
how many millimeters are there in tomato
exactly one value so my scale here is
and this is a very common scale is one
to a thousand can now become important
later on so I find where that 73
millimeters is I measure it out and then
I say okay that's where my edge is so
I'm going to put in let's just suppose
that we 70 millimeters on my diagram
once you've done that you click should
minute all of the rest of them as well
so see this one which is 68 meters I
want to measure from the center measured
out 68 millimeters conduct a survey
that's one scale and then I'm going to
order but I'm going to do the same thing
for all of them going all the way around
so this one 20 la Mina's will be
represented by 21 millimeters 28
millimeters and let's call that advance
- so you're measuring from your center
point out along your radial lines and so
we call them whatever legs the cause
with whatever you measure we drew five
lines that was my suggestion for most of
you some of you may have four or six
even now that we've got our five lines
we've got five points on those lines and
I'm going to join them up so can you do
that with me one that's a lot
okay ultramatic so this being here the
blue thing that's our actual field or
somebody's according to our radial
server now we do lots of things with
this but for now just for today I'm
going to focus just on perimeter there
was the perimeter of this thing
obviously you can walk more the way
around the pipeline's that was easy
so however I got the premier here
because we chose a scale there now I can
use my ruler and I can measure all of
these new length in millimeters maybe
you can leave your disagree if there's
been amended reckon anybody's here so
here's what you do now all your diagrams
do make it flush straight for you but I
think it's a good size if you don't use
your entire page it's got to be a
company at least to speak which into
that party page okay so I think that's a
good sized screen to put a lot of this
diagram it's going to get really busy
really fast
what what you do now is measure each of
the length on the perimeter of your
Pentagon right so just going by mine
when I look at this across here
I'm thinking maybe now end up being
saying 120 millimeters it was 120
millimeters online survey diagram daily
reality it's going to be a hundred
twenty meters mm I feel so I'm going to
measure it and lock it out as such
questions
21:39 I'm going to do the same all the
way around so I'm just going to design
I've got a sling my dreams can make us a
number two
okay so once you've measured with your
Waller because your diagram is to scale
you can use your arm measurements on the
diagram to convert to measurements in
reality and now you can find a premises
and little approx divers a therefore
women are equal and I'm just going to
mark